>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HOPE YOU HAD A GREAT AND
RELAXING THANKSGIVING WEEKEND
AWAY FROM THE ENDLESS DRONE OF
NEWS.
IF YOU SOMEHOW MANAGED TO PULL
THAT OFF A FEW BAY DAYS OF PEACE
AND HAPPINESS WITH THE ONES YOU
LOVED YOU FOUND IT’S LIKE A SPA
TREATMENT AND BETTER OFF FOR IT.
ALSO WONDERING WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT DID YOU MISS OVER THE
WEEKEND?
WE ARE HERE TO TELL YOU.
FOR STARTERS JOE BIDEN BROKE HIS
FOOT IN A COUPLE OF PLACES
SOUNDS SERIOUS BUT DON’T WORRY
ABOUT IT.
BIDEN WAS JUST OUT PLAYING WITH
HIS DOG AS HEALTHY VIBRANT
ADULTS IN FULL COMMANDS OF THEIR
FACULTIES AND NOT AT ALL FRAGILE
AND FADING OFTEN DO.
IT COULD HAVE HAPPENED TO
ANYONE, SERIOUSLY TOTALLY
NORMAL.
CNN IN FACT WROTE A PIECE
CONGRATULATING BIDEN FOR IT.
BIDEN’S INJURIES ARE FAR BETTER
THAN DONALD TRUMP’S SO DON’T ASK
QUESTIONS.
HAVE YOU BIGGER STORIES TO WORRY
ABOUT IN THE NEWS LANDSCAPE.
FOR EXAMPLE, DID YOU HEAR THAT
JOE BIDEN PICKED WOMEN TO LEAD
THE WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS
OFFICE?
THAT WAS HISTORIC MOMENT,
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAS HAPPENED
IN THIS COUNTRY SINCE THE
PRESIDENCY OF DONALD TRUMP.
ANOTHER TRIUMPH FOR THE FORCES
OF IDENTITY.
SYSTEMIC SEXISM FINAL LIVE IN
RETREAT.
NOTHING CAN STOP JOE BIDEN FROM
SMASHING THE GLASS CEILING, NOT
EVEN HIS DOG.
THAT’S WHAT YOU MISSED.
OH, ONE OTHER THING THE
COUNTRY’S PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTABLISHMENT HAS TORTURED YOUR
CHILDREN FOR 8 MONTHS FOR NO
APPARENT REASON.
THAT HAPPENED.
THAT STORY HAS NOT RECEIVED A
LOT OF COVERAGE BUT IT’S BEEN
CONFIRMED TONIGHT.
THE AUTHORITIES HAVE ADMITTED
IT.
60 MILLION AMERICAN CHILDREN
LANGUISHING IN THEIR ROOMS SINCE
SPRING, SITTING IN FRONT OF
SCREENS LEARNING NOTHING
ISOLATED FROM HUMAN CONTACT IN
MANY CASES DRIVEN TO MENTAL
ILLNESS:  WE CAN NOW REPORT
THERE WAS NO REASON FOR ANY OF
THAT THE EXPERTS WERE WRONG.
THEY HAD NO IDEA WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
BUT THE MOST AMAZING PART AND
THIS REALLY IS THE HEADLINE OF
THE STORY.
IS THAT THEY KNEW THEY WERE
WRONG WHEN THEY DID IT.
BUT THEY KEPT LYING ABOUT IT
EVEN AS AMERICAN CHILDREN BEGAN
TO KILL THEMSELVES.
ON SUNDAY IN NEW YORK, CITY
OFFICIALS ALL BUT ADMITTED THIS.
THEY ANNOUNCED THE REOPENING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS.
WHOSE ARE THE SAME SCHOOLS THAT
THEY CLOSED FEWER THAN TWO WEEKS
AGO.
NOW, FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT,
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
NEW YORK DIDN’T GET AN EARLY
SHIPMENT OF THE PFIZER VACCINE
THERE WASN’T SOME GROUND
BREAKING NEW RESEARCH PAPER THAT
REVOLUTIONIZED OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOTHING LIKE THAT AT ALL.
IN FACT, PARENTS SIMPLY HAD
ENOUGH.
THEY FORCED BILL DE BLASIO TO
ADMIT THE OOBOUS.
THIS VIRUS IS NOT A THREAT TO
CHILDREN.
AS DE BLASIO PUT IT IN THAT
WEIRD EUPHEMISTIC I THINK THAT
DUMB PEOPLE SPEAK QUOTE WE KNOW
HEALTH REALITIES FOR THE
YOUNGEST KIDS ARE THE MOST
FAVORABLE.
WELL, YES, WE KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE KNOWN IT FOR A LONG TIME
WE KNEW IT WHEN BILL DE BLASIO
SHUT DOWN NEW YORK SCHOOLS.
AND TONY FAUCI KNEW IT, TOO
THOUGH HE DIDN’T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
NOW HE HAS DECIDED TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT 8 MONTHS
LATE.
HERE’S ANTHONY FAUCI ON SUNDAY.
AND AS YOU WATCH THIS, KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS MAN ON THE SCREEN
IS LEADING OUR RESPONSE,
AMERICA’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> CLOSE THE BARS AND KEEP THE
SCHOOLS OPEN IS WHAT WE REALLY
SAY.
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON’T HAVE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL BUT AS I SAID IN
THE PAST, AND AS YOU ACCURATELY
QUOTED ME, THE DEFAULT POSITION
SHOULD BE TO TRY AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN REASON TO KEEP
THE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL OR TO GET
THEM BACK TO SCHOOL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, THE
SPREAD AMONG CHILDREN AND FROM
CHILDREN IS NOT REALLY VERY BIG
AT ALL, NOT LIKE ONE WOULD HAVE
SUSPECTED.
>> Tucker: OH I HAVE ALWAYS SAID
YOU SHOULD KEEP THE SCHOOLS OPEN
THE MAN IN CHARGE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE TO A NATION
WHOSE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN CLOSED
FOR MONTHS.
I ALWAYS SAID THAT.
CHECK THE TAPE BECAUSE, QUOTE:
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, SAYS
ANTHONY FAUCI, WAIT A SECOND,
WHY IS THIS JUST NOW OCCURRING
TO TONY FAUCI?
ISN’T THIS FAUCI’S ENTIRE JOB
TO, QUOTE, LOOK AT THE DATA?
YES, IT IS.
AND, YET, SOMEHOW HE NEVER
THOUGHT TO DO IT.
THAT’S OUR CARL ROVE CZAR.
OVER THE SUMMER WHEN THE DATA
LOOKED THE SAME AS THEY DO
TONIGHT, FAUCI EXPLAINED THAT HE
COULDN’T REALLY SAY IF KIDS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
IT WAS, QUOTE:  COMPLICATED.
EXCEPT IT WASN’T COMPLICATED.
IT WASN’T COMPLICATED THEN.
IT’S NOT COMPLICATED NOW.
IN APRIL, MANY MONTHS AGO, STUDY
BY THE JOURNAL OF THE PERSONAL
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN WHO GET THE
CORONAVIRUS QUOTE DEVELOP ONLY
MILD SYMPTOMS AND TYPICALLY
RECOVER WITHIN TWO WEEKS.
MONTHS LATER, SAME STORY.
IN JUNE A STUDY IN THE LANCET
AFFIRMED THIS QUOTE COVID-19 IS
GENERALLY A MILD DISEASE IN
CHILDREN INCLUDING IN INFANTS.
OTHER STUDIES FOUND THE EXACT
SAME THING.
NO STUDY HAS FOUND ANYTHING BUT
THAT THERE WAS NEVER MUCH
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
BUT IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR MORE
EVIDENCE, CHECK THE DEATH RATE.
THOSE ARE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
DEATHS ARE NOT HARD TO TRACK.
CONSIDER THE STATE OF NEW
JERSEY.
THAT’S ONE OF THE STATES HIT
HARDEST BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
SO FAR IN NEW JERSEY NOT A
SINGLE SCHOOL-AGED CHILD ALSO A
DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
NOT ONE.
MANY CHILDREN HAVE DIED FROM CAR
ACCIDENTS AND FIRES AND DRUG
ODs AND SUICIDES.
NONE HAVE DIED FROM COVID-19.
IN CALIFORNIA, THE BIGGEST STATE
IN THE UNITED STATES, 40 MILLION
PEOPLE LIVE THERE, A TOTAL OF
TWO PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF 18
HAVE DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
TWO.
THE NUMBERS NATIONWIDE ACCORDING
TO THE LATEST CDC NUMBERS, 123
AMERICANS UNDER THE AGE OF 18
HAVE DIED FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
123 OUT OF 350 MILLION.
WE SHUT THE SCHOOLS ANYWAY.
CRUSHING MILLIONS OF KIDS,
AFFECTING THEIR FUTURES IN WAYS
WE CAN’T EVEN UNDERSTAND AT THIS
POINT BUT IT’S CLEAR IT’S BAD.
REALLY BAD IN SOME CASES.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHY DO WE DO
THIS?
AND THE ANSWER IS TO SAVE THE
TEACHERS.
THE TEACHERS UNIONS PUSHED THIS
AND THEY ARE SERVANTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OBEYED.
SINGLE LARGEST DONORS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO OF COURSE
THEY DID.
UNIONIZED TEACHERS GET TO STAY
HOME COLLECTING CHECKS FOR THEIR
NINE MONTH A YEAR JOBS THESE
CLASSROOMS ARE JUST TOO
DANGEROUS.
IT’S LIKE THE BATTLE OF THE
BULGE FIVE DAYS A WEEK AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
DOES THE DATA SAY ABOUT THIS?
WELL, FOR TEACHERS UNDER THE AGE
OF 50.
AND THAT’S THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM THE ODDS OF SURVIVING A
CONTROVERSIES INFECTION ARE
ROUGHLY 95.98%.
BUT WE SHOULD TELL YOU FOR
TEACHERS UNDER 70, THE RISK OF
DYING HE ESCALATES TO A VERIFYIN
99.5% CHANCE OF SURVIVAL.
AND BY THE IF TEACHERS DO GET
SICK IT LIKELY WON’T BE FROM
TEACHING, CHILDREN APPEAR NOT TO
SPREAD THE CORONAVIRUS.
CERTAINLY NOT EFFECTIVELY.
WE HAVE KNOWN THIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
BACK IN MAY RESEARCHERS IN
EUROPE FOUND, QUOTE, CHILDREN DO
NOT APPEAR TO BE DRIVERS OF
TRANSMISSION AND WE ARGUE THAT
REOPENING SCHOOLS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED SAFE, ACCOMPANIED BY
CERTAIN MEASURES.
AGAIN, NONE OF THIS IS NEW.
TONY FAUCI, THE DATA GUY, KNEW
IT AT THE TIME.
AND SO DID ANYONE IN THE NEWS
MEDIA WHICH COULD READ MOST OF
THEM YET THEY KEPT LYING ABOUT
IT.
ALL OF THEM.
IN JULY, HERE IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE.
A PANEL OF PHYSICIANS AND
EXPERTS ON INFECTIOUS DISEASE
WENT ON TELEVISION TO EXPLAIN
THAT GOING TO SCHOOL ISN’T
DANGEROUS FOR ANYONE.
THEY WOULD SEND THEIR OWN KIDS.
WATCH THE NEWS ANCHOR’S
REACTION.
>> WOULD YOU LET YOUR KIDS GO
BACK TO SCHOOL?
>> I WILL.
MY KIDS ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT.
>> YES.
PERIOD, ABSOLUTELY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AS MUCH AS I CAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WITHOUT A HESITATION.
>> WITHOUT A HESITATION, YES.
>> I HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT
SENDING MY CHILGD TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL.
>> I WOULD LET MY KIDS GO BACK
TO SCHOOL.
>> DR. JOHN TORRES, NBC NEWS.
>> THEY ALL SAID YES.
>> THEY ALL SAID YES SAID THE
READER, FAPPING SHOCK.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
DOCTORS HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR OWN
CHILDREN SHOULD GO TO SCHOOL.
THEY MUST BE CRAZY.
WHAT DO DOCTORS KNOW ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS?
WHAT WAS THIS ABOUT?
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER.
IT WAS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP IN THIS CASE AGREED
WITH THE DOCTORS, THEREFORE, THE
DOCTORS HAD TO BE MOCKED AND
IGNORED.
HERE’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ABOUT SCHOOLS IN JULY.
>> WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
OPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
STOP THIS NONSENSE.
WE OPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: STOP THIS NONSENSE.
WE REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS.
NOW, IN POINTS OF FACT, AS A
SCIENTIFIC MATTER, THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE SOUND POLICY BASED ON
SOUND DATA.
BUT THE MEDIA TOLD US THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF THAT ONE HEADLINE AT
CNN WARNED OF, QUOTE:  THE VERY
CLEAR DANGERS OF DONALD TRUMP’S
PUSH TO REOPEN SCHOOLS.
GOOGLE DIDN’T CENSOR THAT AS
MISINFORMATION.
IT SHOULD HAVE.
ANOTHER HEADLINE CALLED OUT,
QUOTE:  DONALD TRUMP’S MIND
BENDING LOGIC ON SCHOOL
REOPENING.
MIND BENDING LOGIC.
THOSE DAMN DATA AGAIN.
JOE BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN DIDN’T WANT
TO HEAR IT.
THEY DIDN’T WANT YOU TO HEAR IT
EITHER.
SCHOOL WAS DANGEROUS.
PERIOD.
DONALD TRUMP CLAIMED THE
OPPOSITE, THEREFORE, IT WAS TOO
DANGEROUS TO SEND YOUR KIDS OR
FOR YOU TO DECIDE TO SEND THEM.
WATCH.
>> IGNORING HOW THE VIRUS
SPREADS, RISKING TEACHERS AND
PARENTS’ LIVES, GOING AGAINST
THE ADVICE OF EXPERTS.
>> IT’S HAD VERY LITTLE IMPACT
ON YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> DO YOU TRUST HIM TO DO WHAT’S
BEST FOR OUR CHILDREN?
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A TEST.
>> Tucker: YEAH, GOING AGAINST
THE ADVICE OF EXPERTS.
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT’S NO LONGER
ALLOWED.
EVEN AND MAYBE ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE EXPERTS ARE COMPLETELY
WRONG.
WHAT’S THE MESSAGE IN THE
MESSAGE COULDN’T BE CLEARER.
THEY ARE NOT YOUR KIDS ANYMORE.
IF THEY WERE YOUR KIDS, YOU
COULD MAKE THE KEY DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR LIVES.
BUT THEY ARE NOT.
THOSE KIDS, YOUR FORMER KIDS
BELONG TO TONY FAUCI NOW.
TONY FAUCI, AMERICA’S PARENT.
HE WILL MAKE THE DECISIONS ABOUT
YOUR KIDS, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE NATION’S
UBER MOM WHO BY THE WAY IS ALSO
80 YEARS OLD MRS. NANCY D.
PELOSI.
WATCH HER FRET ABOUT THE HEALTH
OF OUR CHILDREN.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS WILL GO
BACK SAFE LIVE TO SCHOOL IN THE
FALL?
>> NO, I THINK WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE SECRETARY WAS
MALFEASANCE AND DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
THIS IS APPALLING.
THEY ARE MESSING, THEY ARE
MESSING, THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE MESSING WITH
THE HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN.
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL IS --
PRESENTS THE BIGGEST RISK FOR
THE SPREAD OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
IF THAT’S NOT CRIMINAL WHAT SHE
JUST SAID, WE MAY NEED TO
REDEFINE WHAT IT MEANS TO COMMIT
A CRIME.
60 MILLION SCHOOL-AGED CHILDREN
AFFECTED BY A DECISION THAT WAS
WRONG.
AND MANY OF THEM HURT FOR LIFE.
BUT WE JUST BLOW RIGHT PAST IT.
AND ALLOW POLITICAL LEADERS LIKE
THAT TO BLOW RIGHT PAST IT WITH
PHRASES LIKE THE HEALTH OF OUR
CHILDREN.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU LOCK
CHILDREN IN THEIR ROOMS IN FRONT
OF SCREENS AND PREVENT THEM FROM
EXPERIENCING HUMAN CONTACT?
HAS NANCY PELOSI EVER BEEN ASK
YOU HAD THAT QUESTION?
HAS SHE EVER WONDER YOU HAD
ABOUT THE ANSWER?
ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL, A TOTAL OF 522
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF 5
AND 14 DIED OF SUICIDE IN 2017.
AND THAT SAME AGE GROUP ONLY 42
CHILDREN HAVE DIED FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS SO FAR THIS YEAR.
WHAT ARE THOSE SUICIDE NUMBERS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IF WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE NANCY PELOSI’S
ADVICE ABOUT THE HEALTH OF OUR
CHILDREN?
WE ALREADY HAVE SOME INDICATIONS
OF THAT.
FUTURE YEARS WILL REVEAL THE
WHOLE PICTURE.
AND YOU CAN BE CERTAIN IT WILL
BE HORRIFYING.
BUT FOR RIGHT NOW, WITH
INCOMPLETE DATA, HERE’S WHAT WE
KNOW.
IN SAINT PAUL, MINNESOTA, FOR
EXAMPLE, 40% OF ALL GRADES GIVEN
THIS YEAR HAVE BEEN F’S.
AND YOU CAN BE CERTAIN THEY ARE
GRADING LIGHTLY.
IT’S STILL DOUBLE THE NORMAL
AMOUNT OF FAILURES.
IN FAIRFAX COUNTY, YEAH.
THE NUMBER OF MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH FAILING
GRADES HAS INCREASED BY 83%.
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE FAILING TWO
OR MORE CLASSES HAS INCREASED BY
MORE THAN 100 PERCENT.
IN A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
HUGE NUMBERS OF KIDS NEVER EVEN
REGISTERED FOR ONLINE CLASSES.
DO YOU HAVE KIDS?
DO YOU KNOW ANYONE WHO DOES?
THEY ARE LEARNING NOTHING.
THOSE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE HEALTH
OF A SOCIETY, LOOK AT ITS YOUNG
PEOPLE.
LOOK AT ITS SCHOOLS.
THESE ARE OBVIOUS POINTS THAT
ARE BEING ROUNDLY IGNORED AND
ANYONE WHO MAKES THEM IS
ATTACKED FOR MAKING THEM.
WE WILL LOOK BACK ON THIS MOMENT
IN SHAME.
BACK IN JUNE WE INTERVIEWED
DR. SCOTT ATLAS WHO WAS THEN A
MEMBER OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.
WEIGH ONE OF THE VERY FEW PEOPLE
THEN OR NOW BRAVE ENOUGH TO MAKE
A SIMPLE POINT.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> BUT THE POINTS ABOUT THE
SCHOOLS IS REALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE THIS IS THE MOST
IRRATIONAL PUBLIC POLICY
PROBABLY IN MODERN HISTORY.
CHILDREN HAVE VIRTUALLY ZERO
RISK OF GETTING A SERIOUS
COMPLICATION.
VIRTUALLY ZERO RISK OF DYING.
YOU DON’T LOCK DOWN THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE YOU ARE PERSONALLY
AFRAID.
THESE TOTALLY OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: DR. SCOTT ATLAS WAS
ATTACKED AS A MONSTER FOR SAYING
THAT REALLY ATTACKED.
DR. TONY FAUCI, BY CONTRAST, WAS
DEFIED.
SIGN SIGNS THROUGHOUT NORTHWEST
D.C. SAID I BELIEVE DR. FAUCI.
THE TRUTH IS THAT SCOTT ATLAS
WAS RIGHT AND DR. FAUCI WAS
REVEALED AS A POWER MAD
INCOMPETENT.
THAT’S NOT OUR OPINION BY THE